what is going on there citizens of the reject
Nation we are here to watch x gon give it
to you fast ex the day John how excited are
you I'm so excited to be back with my family
guys you know what to do go ahead leave a
like that would mean the world we have bought
this v-o-d I'm excited to see Vin D and Jason
Momoa let's swing into it but before that
a word from our sponsor there's an alluring
Aroma in the air thanks to our sponsor scentbird
scentbird is the ultimate fragrance Subscription
Service offering over 600 designer Brands
to choose from they have perfumes cologne
and even unisex options you can find favorites
like Prada Gucci Versace and even some very
much beloved Indie labels for just 17 a month
you get to try a new designer fragrance of
your choice it's flexible too allowing you
to skip any month without penalties and if
you're craving even more variety you can upgrade
to receive two or three products a month each
fragrance comes with a 30 day supply giving
you an opportunity to try right out before
committing to a full bottle I really believe
when it comes to fragrance it's all about
variety and discovering new brands plus as
a married man adding an attractive new scent
can truly spice things up I selected four
fragrances and my wife she loved them all
sweet taboo by Chris Collins warm and inviting
this scent breaks taboos in search of pleasure
Gourmand notes like coffee cardamom and vanilla
create a seductive atmosphere that few can
resist bearberry for men a powerful combination
of green apple and Peach top notes complemented
by Vanilla Jasmine mint lime and Sandalwood
offer a sophisticated Counterpoint to the
Regal sweetness Michael's remains sexual steel
intensely charismatic this fragrance Blends
fresh ginger and smooth Bergamot with the
magnetic lavender and crushed black pepper
it dries down to a seductive mix of metal
Accord masculine leather and musk Mind Games
inspired by the Brilliance of Chess this fragrance
captivates with the Exquisite florals and
transforms into unmatched strength energizing
coffee notes mingle with spicy seduction of
incense mirror and dark wood so ladies and
gents if you want to have fun choosing and
get your first box going click the link below
and use my code rejects for 55 off your first
month at scentbird that's only about eight
dollars for your first month seriously great
deal so thank you again semford for your support
oh yeah totally forgot to mention fully threat
to watch a long race sync up with your own
copy of fast sex that is available for our
super sexual rejects over at our patreon page
feel free to pledge and join us over there
that would mean a lot anyway let's watch this
for real this is a company specifically formed
for a fast move ten years ago yes we're returning
back to Fast Five your mother have understood
this she looked at you and saw a monster I
saw potential are we in the vault it is Dominic
Torito burn what is mine I'll kill Dominic
Toronto no my son we're suffering you soon
never accept death as a payment stupid the
word begins and in there today we'll put our
family on a path to willpower oh do I see
Alan Richardson's body oh is it I heard he's
in is he getting some Reacher [Music] yes
I too remember the best fast and furious
love this rashamon perspective make him suffer
make him suffer make himself
[Music] no I do miss Paul Walker
I would love with the events of this Chase
just set up an alternate timeline
[Applause] last one
I don't remember the events well enough to
remember if that car was the one that got
hit if there was even a Gatling I don't even
remember go back into a side by side
yeah boy
didn't do enough Donuts you had it I didn't
have it you almost had me no one starts at
the Finish Line you gotta have faith oh my
God Little Brian
it's like his old man remember today's lesson
find the line feel the car and let it fly
and win the Oscar
oh yes
Rita Moreno better drive a car by the end
of this movie where's Brian
so much pride a kind of Pride that my son
would have enjoyed if he were here I know
that this road has been very hard what's Dominic's
race
it's a lot of things it is a legacy that will
go on for Generations Legacy no one could
take it away not now not ever yeah not even
Jason Momoa especially not Jason Momoa Roman
asked if he could lead this mission how can
I tell him no simple he's the dumbest one
yeah you should never tell him yes let's spend
the lyrics for Life callbacks oh is that a
call back to the it was like some short film
Vin Diesel directed yeah is that the one I'm
thinking of is that right comment below comment
you're at Vin Diesel directorial efforts expert
I just because certainly sounds familiar
oh oh you all know his name Hold Us in your
heart and you will never lose your way Spirit
of family see you again you know we're in
the car today they said Daddy you're never
afraid I'm afraid of losing a son or a wife
like family no
oh it's [__] hot Lord
you know what you miss why eternity in this
moment
the heart of a warrior
new DeLorean when did this happen
oh my God it's Hobbes got a makeover Oh no
you're marked wait who is this Cipher oh landed
the plane got out of jail imagine killing
you a thousand times
I couldn't reach you then no I can't You're
Gonna Want to hear my last words
don't you think I'd have a goddamn good reason
to be here maybe the only reason that's ever
mattered to you you really shouldn't move
dumb yeah I'm out of targets on your back
this house has been exploded once everyone
knows where you live I'm at the Devil tonight
honestly I always thought it was me so that
was kind of disappointing [Laughter] you're
still the devil don't worry I'm here because
Emily this is you I am a man with no name
Dante Dante Reyes but I need your help
you thought you could use my own move against
me I wasn't talking to you I was talking to
Zeke Kevin's dad oh it's cold it's clever
[Music] oh damn he's good all these henches
have family
oh my god wow it's been right to murder
[Laughter] the rest of you have a choice me
or
that was well done I will remember this I
think everyone will
devil oh and just like that Vin Diesel was
mad at him for stealing the spotlight
that's why you don't put computers in a gun
did you think I would trust you wow
now Cipher is going to kill all their families
just to make a point
ouchy
ah damn it
damn whoa let's get a little of that
you're right here with me
yes [Music]
oh
damn this is awesome at this
oh that was cool
oh wow damn cypher's best scene yeah I try
to get in touch with Roman Ramsay Han no answer
any idea where they might be in Rome working
for you we don't have a mission in Rome Roman
[__] we're going to Rome Roman lead you
and I will finish that driving lesson it's
a promise no matter what happens I always
keep my promises who's gonna stay with him
you're gonna call Brian to babysit well the
sooner we break into the truck and steal the
chip the sooner you get to live La Dolce Vita
Roman the Cowboys almost in position where
the hell are you at Sweet Life of tejan Roman
he's finally leading a mission and it's pointless
yep two tiny tennis wait wait hold up tiny
chairs what are you talking about woman
[Laughter]
just so you know tiny tej's brain still bigger
than yours they gave him like the bobble head
like the Ludicrous video
oh they're just driving looking forward [Laughter]
[Music] come on
multi-skilled these are field hackers it's
really dangerous to be on that oh there's
no one driving it [Music] this vehicle is
just greater alignment yeah this guy's gonna
run over
good luck and a one and a two
[Music] it's a great reaction a little too
much in huh ready oh geez that's a big ass
bomb [Music]
Utah messed up Roman hey dorks what are we
blowing up what Vatican okay I'll do it
I love him put him in every movie I can disarm
it with an agency kill switch I just need
physical hands on the device we have to stop
that truck sorry Captain America again let's
do that did you audition for Captain is that
like an Easter egg Dominic oh come on dammit
he's fast goddamn radius
let's do this [Music] nicely done how did
that work exactly [Applause] wow holy moly
shark's about to go over the hill we have
to crash into it yes we do oh they're gonna
stop it yeah stop the momentum
no we got this what are you gonna do lady
she's gonna pick up the bomb all by herself
throw it into the ocean protect our oceans
little B
itch oh my god wow this is like an Uncharted
level yeah
[Music] [Applause]
there's a wild ass sequence yeah at a good
like call back to the safe a sphere instead
of a cube it's great I think I found our God
[Music] [Laughter] is he gonna like drag the
bomb I don't know
created a cover to cover for them oh wow he
saved their lives damn look at that that cloth
awning really protected those people from
fire and explosion [Music]
oh protect that face
literally his name or his call signal that
laugh of his
oh
yeah nice they are delivering ah
good thing nothing could fall over there never
mind ah that is just Gathering more and more
fire
jeez has like no one died yet that's what's
really good at dodging this bomb oh wow
that fire went out fast
I love that a little bit of water yeah no
no more air intake
good little splash
[Applause] yes
Bravo Ramsay how deep is that River 60 feet
I mean the water could smother the explosion
reduce its power by 10 times maybe oh no
I missed it by that much of how no one suspicious
of him nope we can stop the chase now got
30 seconds to save Rome
the arm to the bomb and you're almost at the
river really oh boy where yeah
oh there's the river yes yes vaticans within
the blast radius get out of there you've done
everything you could not everything oh Jesus
Take the Wheel
s
oh my god wow [Applause] [Music]
push it down dog yes through your suffering
my destiny and find me your pain has just
begun to the pain the Vatican has sustained
some structural damage no lines were claimed
[__] what did they just say first mobilizing
an international future
stealing a 20 kiloton bomb oh come on with
little nobody out of commission and your daddy
in the wind talking to the new boss Showtime
uh-oh so she's the daughter I guess so nobody's
got a family too they ran missions for us
in Abu Dhabi Tokyo London New York that's
their MO to corrupt law enforcement they literally
brought him here to do like a a Reacher performance
yep you know the thing you're doing on your
show do that here what's your point point
is they're criminals Rome was a matter of
time they've stolen hundreds of millions of
dollars in at least one nuclear sub God damn
right great exact footage from the movies
finished effects I'm asking for Full Green
Light Authority killer captured the Toretto
Clan by any means Ames what are you doing
he's going through the Continental you guys
have questions after that comprehensive recap
of the series the team's gone to ground they're
safe for now they've taken Letty whoever did
this wanted to sever your ties to the agency
and isolate you from your family Dominic Toretto
Rogue Nation
our fugitives aren't unknown quantities Toretto
has a sister a son until we find him find
his family you're the new Hobbes Hobbs Reacher
oh boy yeah this is necessary for this little
boy and let's destroy the house again you
really should move
whoa [Music]
oh did Little B do that John Cena that's a
good guess actually I forgot his name Jacob
with a k yes yes good call so Uncle Jacob
your dad sent me yes
[Laughter] kill our allies
[Applause] yes [Music]
wrestling moves [Music]
the base God that one
it's a heavy ass door you okay
the face the agency needs better gear yeah
dude Louis the terrier did an amazing job
with this I'm enjoying this way more than
F9 oh yeah wait oh yeah 100 it's actually
fun yeah oh my God let me drive cool Uncle
Jacob it's not that one it's this one yeah
inconspicuous was that from like 1990 how
about around on me huh
I'm counting on it
how well look there's no code no one's safe
the agency has turned its back on everything
it stood for working with criminals yep Hernan
Ray is still pretty dead he has a son Dante
Letty letty's in a black site prison off of
every map and get her out nobody can but you're
a nobody you are a nobody what you're asking
me to do is impossible
Jesus will be with you yes my first family
nothing's impossible
this movie pushing religion on me or need
your agenda okay
undisclosed location Germany
what the hell keeping her in an Indiana Jones
tomb fancy coat expensive earrings those gotta
hurt whoa nice I'm out here for the agency
I'm gonna get you out of here but it's gonna
take some time you didn't come all this way
without a plan game recognizes game oh first
let's get you out of the cell It's Gonna Hurt
me open the door smart
really yeah really no smart she's moving you
I'm just looking for someone how can we help
sure Kentucky you already did I saw the subtitles
oh my God ready to roll never mind who is
this Daniella melchior I'm not sure she usually
has shorter hair [Applause]
a million dollars for whoever can beat me
no he's dressed love it full hairy styles
this looks like a genie rub the car three
times and make a wish I'm Dante I'm Shantae
[Laughter] you remember my father I remember
he thought he had his foot on a serious neck
but you know what happened he got his next
step is mine and I own this thing nice
loyalty
she can't buy the streets sure you can though
the streets the streets are typically going
for a price we race if you win you take me
in if you lose don't lose contractually I
can't Let's Race [Music] no we're putting
our attention to the side everybody Stow your
weapons I actually like their back and forth
yeah it's been a long time since I've been
like oh I've seen Vin Diesel bounce off to
someone yeah well there's contrast now
I'm just here to wreck all of the like forced
gravitas I know what you're thinking and yes
carpet matches the drapes thank you
you've saved so many lives oh I know I can't
figure it out how do you choose the ones you
save uh-oh what does he put on the line
oh look at that it's like out of the first
movie yeah
like actual Jason no it seems like nobody
directed him just let him take carp launch
to be everyone I love it it works though oh
you're too eager
oh no choice
he wouldn't put a bomb under her car [Music]
did uh you gotta save her
what are you gonna save him he knows him but
he's gonna save both of them [Music] looks
like you made your choice [Applause] ah trick
question everyone dies
well done
[Music] they saved the semi-famous one yep
[Music]
like a little John yeah because I'm out of
here you're still beautiful I saved you for
your looks let me wipe this one piece of dirt
off your face did you know whoa listen to
me did you know that I was legally dead for
two minutes two minutes
yes
[Music]
he's the Joker Batman of the Joker and everyone
drives at the Batmobile should we take all
their money oh my yes he totally Richard them
too nope there are a lot of plots in this
movie that's what I come here for just like
just like cutting to so many different plots
eyes open hold still don't smile like that
it's unsettling your new name is Chester Chester
and you're on a kayaking trip with your handsome
ripped Uncle Roger Chester and Raj we gotta
get ready to fight wait so we need guns artillery
tanks yeah but how we gonna get that with
no money we've been hacked you guys are the
hackers we need more computing power yeah
we're gonna do that if we broke what do you
mean we broke
oh my God Roman you did something smart I'm
a grown ass
yes
you remind me who I was all alone didn't you
from The Moment I Saw You sisters [Laughter]
yeah does anyone and only child in this universe
you know Elena she knew everything about the
Reyes family after they killed her husband
she dedicated her life trying to take them
down I think I still have her files you just
have her files yep so remember her by if I
die I want you to have my case files for me
you
Freddie Merc we need transport weapons cars
and quietly cool but I'm just gonna need cash
oh the black Jeff Bezos here's got you covered
I won't even cover the muffins this guy serious
yes Han might get his personality back damn
yeah I want an acid trip race sequence that's
all they do is talk and then everyone has
to do their job and yours he's fantastic you
know what I'm saying hey guys this is a family
environment it's a family
Gentlemen please guys you guys supporting
like dozens of dollars in damage dozens of
dollars in tears beat your ass you just beat
my ass beat my ass oh my God just please look
how sweaty tires it looks like Hobbs from
Fast Five
they're secretly related
that easy huh why would you ever what
they like to fix things before they break
them sick Place Letty Minority Report what
did you do I rerouted an aesthetic gas into
their air conditioning how'd you do that without
look looking she knows rasheed's that well
why would they put it right where your hand
would be
no I do how much time do we have about four
minutes it'll have to do yes get a fight in
there I'd stay down if I was you I like Charlie's
throwing a lot in this movie yeah two baddest
ass ladies and Showbiz getting a showdown
yeah yes ouch
Sam
[Music] what on Earth guys yeah four minutes
I think that was the most unbelievable thing
that's happened so far
yeah ouch pocket glass
sociopathic tendencies from an early age he
bounced from juvie to prison to mental words
and each time daddy was there to Spring him
out talk about a glow up properties raise
on before he died the police station and guess
whose name is on indeed my fun man sit there
it stands to reason we're gonna get up and
go to the bathroom ready
not suspicious we all need to go to the bathroom
yep at the same time it's gonna be a lot of
space on this flight
oh
now let's lose our tail we going skydiving
oh what they're just flying is that a little
plane you know how to Glide so we need thrust
fuel alcohol right so three tiny bottles of
alcohol okay that's more like it that's Rose
not gonna work long story a good initiative
I want to hear you tell that story I'm glad
it wasn't the height enjoy the ride that'll
be stay based hi base even if you're not scared
of heights it's pretty terrifying guys hold
back no no that's a bad idea I mean like Roman
level bad uh
oh it's these guys no no it's it's Cliffhanger
from last to Statham uh of course there you
go okay I have something to talk to you about
the only reason a dead guy shows up in my
door
[__]
[Music]
oh
go there
and this is how we Bond Wowie
I'm trying to kill me too enemy of my enemy
wow nicely done tej man
yeah I guess so now both of you come to the
barbecue
hello Dominic until now you have lived your
life a quarter mile at a time you know what
I can't figure out how someone born so rich
chooses the poorest path of life oh bars I'm
gonna break yours the game's not over yet
there's still so many people to hurt
oh [__] damn it Toretto freeze time to
face the music Dom they're playing right into
his hands cop what surprised celebrities Gonna
Save Dominic's Roto now he's trying to tear
us apart they've been paid to Target us and
anyone who ever helped us until now Queenie
mother mom I'll have transport waiting for
you and where are you going I want to dig
some Graves with all these guns what are you
doing preparing for what's
to come
oh he protected Jack Reacher
I feel like I tried doing the cool walk and
then
oh this also looks like the same freeway from
that one Mission Impossible fight drink the
gasoline yes become a car
it'll happen by the last movie
I'm listening now ah God is respect I mean
he could tell that Dom's not really the bad
guy you never know he can stay committed is
he picking up a car he is turning a car over
with one hand he's got he's doing everyone
he's the car Whisperer
[Music]
my family
hey oh [__] with the drip
yes the Moa has no contract
it hurt me
yep
Swan guy
oh got rid of the vest
oh no she's in Peril I can't save them all
five four you can't see me go on
yes Warrior and his shield gotcha you killed
my father on this bridge and now I know where
to find your son you're gonna be okay I got
her go save your son my nephew exactly yeah
I'm not gonna say I'm sorry so let me do you
one better let's get your son did everyone
hear that conversation apparently so you know
all that fire and destruction it's not that
loud project I've been working on
we're going back to space
we gotta go
[Applause]
oh oh yeah oh my missile launcher damn whoa
collateral damage stuck stuck you gotta crawl
out there kid there's an Airfield seven clicks
West okay we'll meet you there now open the
back up there's really nowhere to land who
said anything about Landing you got to get
to the land yeah to use the car you will need
to be on just jumped off I think
oh my goodness
[Laughter] [Music]
wow the guys Dominator is a superhero we just
got to accept it but they're still on your
tail
it's jammed oh what are you doing yep you
knew this was coming Pete
come on base God you got this
oh my God
ah damn it I would love a scene with him
Dominic welcome to the Big Show dance the
last laugh check out my co-pilot welcome back
three Dom please don't kill Dante save him
for the sequel yeah you need him please looks
like my fuel line's been shot I can't get
to him Dom Jacob stay with me jump into his
car you're the star of this movie Dumb
[Music] Jesus Take the Wheel
no [Music] no don't worry in the sequel we'll
see how we got out yeah he he jumped out at
the last rolled off the freeway
take away the streets nah take the Dom out
of the streets but you can't take the streets
out of Dom [Music]
nah saves everything do it my turn
[Music]
oh jeez he defeated the two helicopters now
let's finish that driving lesson feel the
car find your line and fly what does that
mean she's gonna jump out or something
yeah
oh my God is he gonna catch his son yeah part
of flying is the only one to jump out yeah
yeah that's part of the driving part of the
drug
s that's what I'm talking about [Music]
no don't kill him [Music]
how does he know for sure Optimus Prime I'm
gonna get it he's showing off in front of
your son but honestly did you really think
it was going to be that easy easy he threw
helicopter calvary's here we got you Dom an
get out of here it's a trap Robin you're a
terrible leader
everybody get in a car
whoa see that's the problem with having a
big family oh my God can't protect them all
he's looking right at the camera no no
think everyone's going to end up on your side
problem is amso's mine first Jack how could
you I told you that was him damn excellent
cash it looked like his frame yeah and that
hair
the next villain is always literally just
around the corner what a mislead we thought
it was our next Hobbs yeah they used Jack
Reacher against us he made one mistake you
never took my car yes yep drive down that
damn dumb [Music]
[Music]
let's go let's go
this is what the universal ride should feel
like [Music] oh this is great
no then also gonna come in handy John of course
whoa whoa yes the nice shot
the Flames are only helping yes he's gonna
time travel [Music] way back in the past right
before the first movie [Music] now Drive underwater
yes turn into a submarine live life four knots
at a time suffering is over Dom it's time
for you to die
oh excellent he knows he needs to do all that
to take him down yep
crater with an alien ship
the submarine is back Now where's Hobbs to
ride that missile huh
oh my God is it hurts
away still think my plan sucks girls get it
done got Wonder Woman we got the Old Guard
all the supers are here
oh damn what a weird spot to end this really
is like a chapter break now let's watch that
post credit scene that everyone wanted us
to know about oh here it is oh
take it off come on howdy partner do you like
surprises you've done some dastardly Dirty
Deeds Sheriff he took the most important thing
of my life for me yep you don't get off so
easy Dom drove the car help me you pulled
the trigger yeah this should have been your
enemy this whole movie yeah pretty much since
when does Luke Hobbs go anywhere with this
much on his face when you give her a reveal
yes there he is The Devil Is Coming For You
law man lying hard to find you some [__]
standing ass
all right I did miss him I knew it was kfabe
all along over Ephesus on some [__] damn
all right so is that his spin-off movie is
gonna be him versus Dante
yeah I don't know alrighty let's talk about
it alrighty well I actually thought the movie
was a lot of fun I like it I instantly could
tell within like the first 30 to 40 minutes
I like it more for definitely more than F9
that's for sure and uh I would say that ultimately
I actually liked it um a lot more than fate
of the Furious as well I definitely wouldn't
put it both like Fast Five or even the two
installments that came after it uh but this
definitely brought it back more to yeah this
is just genuinely fun I had this worry in
the first like 30 minutes when I was having
fun of okay it's a fast and furious movie
though at some point this has become like
a tedious Adventure right we're gonna be like
this is going on a little too long do I feel
like it's a little too long I don't even know
if it's really length that's the problem it's
really that's just some stuff wasn't as there's
some stuff that definitely loses steam it's
momentum the engine stops revving for certain
plot lines that you cut back to uh around
like the hour and a half mark that there's
some plot lines that just didn't we're just
not as engaging however though overall I still
feel like it didn't ever get to a point where
it completely lost it it never get the movie
itself in total it never reached a point where
I was like I'm ready to leave I'm ready to
check out once it's gonna wrap up because
there'd always be something that eventually
pulls me back in uh I thought this was a blast
of a film overall so yeah that's just my general
thoughts off of the experience uh coming off
of it but yeah John what do you think I also
had a blast with the furious and I was also
you know second that I think it's easily better
than at least the previous two installments
because it did have yeah a sense of fun the
entire time the serious stuff the Vin Diesel
trying to win an Oscar stuff is tempered well
enough to sell what they want you to care
about and I feel like they in this movie especially
kind of realize that part of the magic is
that yeah you're gonna have some stuff that's
crazy and CG elevated and you know Larger
than Life most definitely but I thought they'd
managed to do a nice balance of stuff that
felt at least like real stunts real cars getting
crashed and banged up and then you have your
you know him throwing helicopters at things
and all that other Jazz and uh and yeah you
know certain plot lines were more interesting
than others but I was kind of interested at
least in what everyone was doing so it was
just kind of a matter of to what degree yeah
and uh yeah there were I mean we'll we'll
wait and see if uh Jacob Toretto remains dead
but you know like that was kind of a surprise
I mean like I've kind of gotten used to not
being as surprised by things they're doing
in these movies now um but yeah I don't know
I thought everybody got a chance to shine
and uh it like I said I think the most important
thing like like you touched on is is the fun
factor and yeah I was never zoning out I was
never like come on or or getting sort of that
mind numb effect when it's just too much like
craziness in your face um so yeah I thought
they managed to bring this down to the the
level I was hoping for that I like from these
movies certainly yeah it's weirdly it's not
the craziest Fast and Furious movie it's definitely
to me it's not I've heard some people say
that I'm like I don't know this is the craziest
one to buy a long shot like the rock hanging
off a sub and like guiding a missile or them
going to space I mean they mention those things
but yeah like they do they do some like crazy
ass [__] in here in his Dominic Toretto
more of a superhero now more than ever I'd
say so yeah it's definitely like that's kind
of like the best role that they give him here
is just to be some guy who's he's most interesting
in action scenes and I thought he thought
he was fine um like here's the thing what
I heard I heard a few things um that Jason
Momo is great and I heard that this movie
has an ending that upset a lot of people because
it's just sort of abruptly ends it's not a
very well handled cliffhanger that is probably
the best thing I could have heard about this
movie because it prepared me for that to not
be like what the hell in fact I was able to
be like okay I feel like it's about to end
yeah I was able to actually sense it's about
to end right now yeah because everyone who
like was upset about it I kind of heard them
complain about that which made me go okay
I'm ready for I think this I think this is
the portion when it's gonna end so when it
ended I'm like yeah definitely doesn't feel
like a complete movie it doesn't like it doesn't
feel like they they told us a a really specific
story within this chapter one of this fast
X Trilogy yeah it does not it feels like a
mid-season finale but I was so prepared for
it that I wasn't bothered because everyone
else had really prepared me for it so I'm
grateful for that the Gal Gadot thing was
not um ruined for me although I feel like
it was it was like room for me like a year
ago like everyone was talking to me yeah I'd
forgotten all about it time we got it but
she was there I was like oh yeah yeah that's
right she's supposed to be here raises a lot
of questions it does like where the hell has
she been she's working with Cipher of all
people to be working with yeah that's a little
questionable um she looks great if she seriously
like I don't believe Jacob's dead no one can
really die this is a supernatural element
even even um Alan richson whose name character
I've not committed a memory yet but Alan Richardson
or Jack Reacher yeah even Ames I think Ames
there it is even he says like ungodly things
or a godly or Defying Gravity yes I'm lying
about it that's acknowledging the Ridiculousness
of what they can accomplish and I'm like all
right well I guess they have meta-humans in
this universe Dominic Toretto and the family
are part of that this is the birth of metahumans
yeah uh but Jason Momoa uh here's the thing
I was expecting everyone else would be boring
and Jason Momoa would be the only thing entertaining
and what I was surprised by was I liked a
lot more of the people here that I actually
originally anticipated I would ultimately
walk out of this film saying I enjoyed quite
a bit of the characters but Jason Momoa is
definitely the Highlight uh undoubtedly no
no amount of Praise actually prepared me for
it I really do love him yeah 100 and I think
you need his presence because you know with
both Vin Diesel and and you know the installments
that feature Dwayne Johnson even though Dwayne
certainly seems like he's more apt to do you
know the comedic side they both are taking
certain things really seriously and I think
it helps this movie to have such an anarchic
presence and such a gleefully anarchic presence
to contrast all that so that VIN can go and
again try to win that Oscar but you have you
know the Joker Counterpoint to his Batman
he's very much he's he's doing Joker just
without a high-pitched voice he leans more
into the troubled boy about it like we're
Joker has the more of the mysterious element
there's no mystery to this guy yeah that's
that's the one thing that I would be like
he's not exactly Joker because there's zero
mystery his origin story is very specific
and there's a one right answer and it's my
daddy yeah yeah and they do have the thing
about him going into like mental ward units
and all that fun stuff uh but he was he was
so natural that it doesn't feel like he's
forcing anything at all nor is he playing
up the psychotic level to the point where
he's like I'm playing it crazy you know he's
just he seems so naturally this guy yeah and
if you watch enough Jason Momoa interviews
this seems more like Jason Momoa now more
than ever weirdly even because he's in a villainous
shoes but he's so aware of what the world
is that it needs that that the scenes with
him like okay by comparison him and Jason
Statham I don't find that in Vin Diesel and
Jason Statham I don't find that interesting
when they're talking to each other Vin Diesel
and Cypher I don't find that interesting when
they were talking to each other in any of
the films Vin Diesel and John Cena in the
last one don't find that interesting but as
you said the contrast between the two different
types of personalities just when they're interacting
with each other it's actually engaging like
if any of those rumors are true about Vin
Diesel being upset about Jason Momoa in the
show like my God you would be doing yourself
a massive disservice because he helps make
you more interested when Vin Diesel is this
is my my takeaway with the cast was he's one
of the least interesting people because he's
he's fun when he's like I like watching him
in the action just because of the Ridiculousness
of this this Godly presence that Vin Diesel
inhabits of being that just uh redefined Dominic
Toretto over this franchise but he does make
him a more interesting character than ever
than the last few films have made him and
so you need Jace like Vin Diesel needs Jason
Moet for Vin Diesel to be more interesting
yeah well I think it circumvents some of that
stuff I mean I don't know what the actual
contracts are but it circumvents the things
that can become also boring about the stakes
from what we know about that to have just
a guy who yeah is here to torture him and
he almost never he's so often talking to him
over walkie-talkies or from afar and he's
just trying to bust his chops and make him
sweat and I think that's a great way to have
Vin Diesel take some hits without having literally
taking some hits yeah and he's a villain who's
willing to get hit yeah totally and get hurt
he really is just I just love how the more
you break it down he is just Joker without
the mystery even right down to like giving
you choices and [__] like that and testing
yes exactly
you know Joker yeah which yeah I think uh
this franchise I think the further it has
arced into that Superhero you know Larger
than Life territory I think one thing that
they have kind of overlooked is the idea that
you do need a larger than life villain who's
not just you know mean mugging and trying
to out muscle you know whoever you know Vin
Diesel whoever um and yeah I mean like I think
some of the plot elements didn't always serve
the characters but I was always happy to be
with any set of characters we cut to I know
uh the the Roman tejan stuff wasn't like the
most engaging plot but I still liked hanging
out with them I still like getting to meet
Pete like Pete Davidson Cameo uh real quick
and and you know various of the like Cipher
and uh and Letty I think is like a cool Prospect
for the future well they see Chris Morgan
is did not write this and it was Justin Lynn
and some other guy Dan something so um yeah
what has he done I don't know I just know
his name because it sounds like miso from
Mr Sunday movies yeah I don't I don't know
what else this guy has done and I feel like
that's where Chris Morgan's chops come in
handy is for handling Roman because I felt
like this was the most boring Teja ever was
sure that that whole section of them like
it started off engaging like I like I liked
the setup of oh this is Roman taking the lead
and it actually could have done something
a little more interesting that they could
have leaned into with they they acknowledge
it they have a scene that talks about it how
this was Roman's you know chance to take a
lead and he total and essentially the whole
thing got botched so it could have been something
that was more they could even lean not I don't
even mean lean into it in a way with like
dramatic weight I I they could have deleted
to it with like comedy even they could have
done something but it was so underwritten
and it ranged from mediocreally entertaining
watching them to just honestly boring it was
years it was always in that range for me of
mediocre to boring if they'd really embraced
yeah that role that loss for him and that
kind of crisis of just like my role on the
team and my my wanting to step up like yeah
if they had really embraced that that could
have been an endearing thing for those characters
to do rather than devolving into just like
ah we gotta chase a bunch of mcguffins and
money and stuff around and just like genuinely
fun banter like that wasn't even existing
there the whole thing with like uh Han tripping
out honestly one of the things such a missed
opportunity I feel like the last couple films
have really botched is Han you know part of
me was going is he's just still like weird
grieving guy right now like I was kind of
getting it with the character portrayed on
the last one because he's been like an assassin
or some [__] I don't know my memory barely
serves me on what they said about it what
he's been doing uh and I was like is he missing
Giselle this time around or something but
then I wait no I mean you see him in Tokyo
Drift if you're going by order of timeline
that was after giselle's death and he is a
blast to watch in Tokyo Drift so here Han
returning was such an exciting thing and they
don't do anything really with Han that makes
him fun and he's like actually kind of boring
now he's owed a big moment or something and
the big moment ought to have come with his
confrontation with Shaw yeah and that just
turned into a whatever fight scene a quick
snack fight and then a quick way to resolve
their their score basically yeah when that
could have been uh the thing that we were
all kind of waiting for that they even teased
in the trailer and it would have been hype
yeah and it didn't they didn't do anything
with it and I like Jason Statham's presence
a lot I really feel like he adds something
this is one of those franchises where the
celebrities that really do feel add something
um even if they're on screen only briefly
because like he's only there for a minute
and two like the other you know it's like
Scott Eastwood shows up for a half a second
and like they all like I noticed that was
like even though you have your main components
of the characters you're mainly cutting to
even the people who are just part of the overall
franchise who don't spend much time in the
movie I didn't really feel like we're slighted
by that fact Cipher this is even though this
is the least amount of screen time she gets
in a fast and furious movie this is to me
the best she's ever been she was easily the
most fun to watch this time around something
about putting her in the muck of things having
her be introduced in a way that is a much
more gritty and grimy like she's beating up
she's against she's not the top dog like sure
last time she's like imprisoned whatever she's
still like neat and prettied up and whatever
and she still like gives that air of being
in control yeah and here having to like figure
her way out even as ridiculous as it is with
you know the whole thing with her what device
they left by her hand but her scenes are actually
entertaining she's I I always thought that
it's Charlize Theron and they just gave her
stoic boring villain yeah and the last two
films like there was always something that
I felt could have reached a much higher potential
and here I actually found that this is where
they captured the energy that Charlize Theron
could bring right down to her fight scenes
which I thought were great great uh anytime
she was on screen I actually thought like
here this is what I've this is Charlie stair
like yeah this is the star right here I find
you very entertaining right now and anytime
she was on screen and I'm actually excited
to see her in the future with Letty in that
whatever Odd Couple you know relationship
that's gonna lead to down the line and you
know her ultimate retribution I'm sure yeah
now what do you think about John Cena being
redone uh hey man I mean like it was such
a blast to watch him and I actually really
enjoyed him and little B together uh you know
praise be the base God uh yeah like I I was
you know you're in congress with the previous
installment or not I just enjoyed watching
him that much more and I think they're smart
enough to know that yeah his Charisma and
his fun energy is a big you know thing people
come for but also something that these movies
I think can use it's uh I I forgive it because
yeah even though he was a super intense last
time I think you know this movies these movies
need as many splashes of Personality as they
can get and you know even though like some
of the most ridiculous stuff like them coming
on the plane and everything is like again
hyper ridiculous uh I I was still really into
that and I liked the family aspect of that
and even though I don't think he's dead I
like the idea of wondering anyway so yeah
I mean I don't mind them completely changing
the character or anything like that and uh
and I liked uh the addition of Brie Larson
for like the the small amount she's not like
the most impactful character they add but
you know to to flesh out Mr nobody's family
I thought she got to strut some of that coolness
and some of that attitude that you know everything
you see Brie Larson and now you're like so
is this gonna hearken to what could be improved
about her portrayal of Captain Marvel and
uh you know watching this I'm like okay like
yeah you can bring some of that attitude and
some of that SASS and whatnot and I hope they
give her more to do next time um yeah I think
they'll probably give her more to do it's
pretty Larson they're setting her up absolutely
and I mean just so many like crazy cool like
the the whole bomb through Rome I thought
was a nice they literally pointed out for
us in the movie but I thought it was a nice
Counterpoint to the safe thing and two watching
them kind of re-contextualize I mean these
movies are like Saw movies in the sense that
like every next installment is based off of
something that was like just in the Next Room
from one of the last sequels or something
and uh and I think that's that's a fun gag
but I also thought that the way they showed
you the opposite perspectives was nicely at
least in this immediate experience nicely
handled and I thought Louis letaria overall
just stepping into the director role brought
a lot of energy and made it really kind of
flow more than I expect these movies to flow
I think he's a very underrated director sure
I I think an Incredible Hulk movie I feel
like as an underwriting movie overall especially
the action scenes that he has there I think
are very exciting sequences I I loved a lot
of the fights that he does there The Transporter
movies that he held I thought are really really
really fun uh so it's cool seeing him reunite
with Jason Statham here um John and I are
the only fans of the movie the one with Jet
Li yeah so I overall I think he's a very underrated
director because he knows how to make a really
entertaining film and he had big shoes to
fill at a last minute decision you know with
Justin Lin stepping away three days before
or something yeah he had a real tough tough
situation and a big challenge ahead of him
and while I I don't really often find you
know what makes it's it's always difficult
for me to truly pinpoint what makes their
style distinct when it comes to the Fast and
Furious franchises only once in a I'll be
like I guess this kind of looks like a shot
from that director that I know but more often
than not it's like what I like about Louis
the Terrier's work is he he has a good spirit
about it and I feel like that Spirit he really
brings here brings it to life and he's got
just the right amount of cheese in order to
make it to still enjoyable like he brings
a sense of self-awareness to her like this
was the the first one in a couple films where
I felt like the the gravity toss never weighed
the film down even though clearly Vin Diesel
still really wants that he's moving I never
felt like it reached a point where this is
too much and it's boring so I really I really
do credit his work and I think I don't know
whose decision it was for John Cena uh to
come back around like this but I didn't even
like John Cena in the last movie took a lot
of the fun out of watching John Cena yeah
I thought I found myself laughing at him a
lot well that's the thing is this this also
had the right kind of cheese and it's very
easy as we've seen in the last two installments
especially actually to fall into the wrong
kind of cheese that does not help the experience
yeah and Brie Larson's like fun and Charming
is there a chance to actually be herself a
little bit more as well like I think that's
part of the fun of when you cast these guys
is seeing them get to be more what they're
really like and I think the franchise has
been smart enough to lean into that with a
lot of these cast of characters Alan richson
uh was essentially doing what we know from
Jack Reacher to be just with a villainous
twist yes he's not as well jackridge was a
lot smarter but it's just pretty much it's
very much a Jack Reacher kind of role uh and
and all if Jack Reacher wasn't a loner um
but yeah that was that was fine if I didn't
recognize his build at the beginning I would
I don't think I would have predicted it I
mean even even wrecking even recognizing his
build at the beginning I still didn't ultimately
predict it I was like oh maybe I just misread
it yeah sure that's a great catch though yeah
his body looks he's very large man yeah yeah
you know he's got he's got a very specific
looking build and I mean uh Danielle and melchior
I thought like she's hardly in this but I'm
excited to see her a little bit more maybe
hopefully in the next one she's family now
and I thought the kitty was a little Brian
did a fine job if yeah he did a fine job everyone
did good everyone did good overall don't know
what happened with Mia but sure she was around
for a little bit um she's chilling I feel
like uh they should she's seeing that the
house gets rebuilt a third time yeah yeah
overall I thought this was a really fun movie
and of course the action scenes they were
they didn't just feel like noise to me you
know I I thought there was a lot of Craftsmen
shipped to the action yeah the bomb through
Rome as insane as it is as not realistic as
it is it was I was still able to follow it
and you could still tell when a lot of stuff
was practical yeah tangible still you got
to mix on a lot and that's where tangible's
the right word for it because I think the
franchise lost a lot of its tangibility yeah
you have to have this right realm of I believe
what's happening you need the stunts and you
need some real destruction because that especially
in movies that center around cars that sells
everything yeah I think especially F9 and
fate of the Furious got to that point where
you're like if you're doing all CG you know
that's in a movie like this that is very much
straddling the line of like all the craziness
is done with very real machines you could
see go outside and see you need yeah that
grounding in the Practical stunt worked at
least for the things that can be achieved
that way well yeah they always have had a
bit of practical stunt work but they it tends
to get kind of lost I think and here it didn't
ever get lost for me well here it seemed like
a priority to do it in camera when they could
yeah uh it's that sequence even the even the
race car I remember seeing the trailer and
laughing at the fact that they have a race
car sequence happening here like what this
is weird but with the objectives and that
Jason Momoa has with the way how he loves
the toy with people and how he is kind of
doing this thing where he wants to prey on
memory and he's doing this there's a there's
a real uh theatrical dramatic experience that
he tries to provide with the suffering you
know he'll flat out say like see what I did
with the with the bomb it was the play on
the on the safe or um this is the freeway
where it all happened you know like he likes
to have this these theatrics that I think
are a lot of fun yeah and he's defacing these
sacred cows things like that yeah and so even
going to the race car I'm like okay this actually
it actually works sometimes they are Dom's
home now sometimes you try to shoehorn the
racing back in here and you're like this doesn't
need to be here but this actually worked it
really it was it was actually kind of clever
of how they brought it back in um yeah I don't
the it sure just I didn't in the middle number
but I don't ever come here for I mean I don't
know for structure I don't realize I showed
up for like like a complete narrative and
and then of all the franchises ever I mean
this is one where you you know the story is
not ending so why not you know there's enough
of a climax that it's clear this is a chapter
break and at worst it feels like you know
some mid-season finale work it's clear we'll
be back yeah um I feel like they should still
end it on I don't know if a two more is where
they should do I still think they should end
it in the next one uh like the original plan
that they had we'll see yeah I I I I feel
like they could find stuff to do but part
of me is like man if they could just nail
a one-two punch to send things off that would
be pretty gratifying actually after all this
because I mean for the ups and downs the fast
franchise I would argue that for fans for
for people who enjoy these it's probably got
more it's got a decent record between hits
and misses so like they I don't know the Yeah
the more you expand this out the more worried
I get even though I'm sure they don't want
to stop just yet also making less and less
money in the states it's not is this is not
considered a I feel like it's actually not
considered a success in the states uh it's
just why they're really not digital uh sure
yeah um but the but the film internationally
is doing extremely well yeah uh as it should
with its multiple ethnic cats it should do
very very well yeah it's Globe trotting everyone's
represented in the fast family they pretty
much are sure I mean it's a very Multicultural
family and it's and they go all over the world
and and even though they destroy a lot of
it they seem to appreciate it when they're
not trying to destroy it yeah well uh I don't
know what do you guys think about the movie
did you guys like it overall did you have
fun with it I I think this was a I think this
was a good return to a genuinely enjoyable
film and I had I had a lot of fun with it
and uh glad we bought it it was worth the
money alrighty guys we'll leave your thoughts
down below uh you can subscribe leave a like
and let's end this with a patron
flev DeLorean because they had a new DeLorean
in this movie and if there's anybody I would
love to see you know peel up uh and you know
Screech come to a screeching halt you know
tires blazing and then throwing open those
Gull Wing doors and stepping out and informing
me that I have two seconds to decide whether
or not to get in the car with you I would
get in that car with you I would trust you
with my life Flav no matter what crazy Globe
spanning mystery Espionage Mission you are
on I will trust you if you look at me you
know when we're on top of a crumbling building
or something and you're like John do you trust
me I would be like of course Flav I will jump
off of anything you tell me to I will drive
into anything you tell me to and I will act
without thinking if you tell me to nice that's
what we do for family flev and you can't spell
flev uh without you know the letter F which
is the first letter of the word family and
there's also an L in family and that's the
second letter of your name and uh and your
last name has an i in it so we're halfway
to family already buddies so uh keep up the
good work keep saving the world and we'll
catch you next time love you stay pledged
I don't know how you doing John it's the NOS
[Music] foreign